are you feeling uncomfortable insecure
scared anxious a fraud well if so then
you might very well be experiencing
impostor syndrome impostor syndrome
isn't simply a fear of failure it's a
fear of the inevitable moment that
people will find out that you don't know
what you're doing it's the constant
questioning about whether you belong and
the nagging feeling that you'll never
live up to the expectations that you
feel other people have for you I know
you might see things that I've done the
past interviews games successes and you
might feel that I have known exactly
what I was doing along that route but I
want to let you know that throughout all
of those times I was simply a girl
following a path just going with the
flow never really knowing what I was
doing I want you to know that I get so
nervous before I sing that I usually
don't talk to anyone for about an hour
beforehand because I'm too busy freaking
out inside my head yeah you'll be fine
babe and I get so anxious about
interviewing people or perhaps sometimes
just even talking to people in general
that I overanalyze everything that I've
said days or weeks after wondering did I
come across as stupid here will I be
remembered in a negative light and now
that I've graduated University and found
myself a job in the games industry which
is something that I've worked hard for
four years
I still find myself questioning whether
I should really be here and how long
it's going to last I basically want you
guys to know that I have impostor
syndrome or I did all right I sometimes
do but why am I saying all this to you
well I'm showing this with you because
the way that I'm getting over it is by
realizing that this feeling it's
universal if you feel like you don't
know what you're doing you are
definitely not alone in that ask
yourself if you enjoy what you're doing
not if you're good at it if you enjoy it
and ask yourself if you're comfortable
in the environment that perhaps you're
working in or you're living in and if
the answer to both of those is yes and
you still feel like an impostor then my
advice to you is to accept it we cannot
and should not know everything so my
personal interests lie in the creative
industry and it's been quite
mind-blowing to me to see how many
people have actually stood up and
accepted and shared that they to feel
like an imposter sometimes and they
don't know everything within the field
that they're working in it's interesting
to notice how many well-respected people
that are in the industry that actually
open up about the struggles that they
deal with and who's listening to those
people I realized that being open and
honest and authentic to your true self
Garner's a lot of respect
not because people are looking up to you
as someone who is better or more
knowledgeable but instead because these
people are able to make others feel like
they belong I'm just telling you off the
bat that I don't know anything and if
there's one thing that characterizes my
writing is that I always start from that
realization and I do what I can to keep
reminding myself of that during the
process I think we try to be experts
because we're scared we don't want to
feel foolish or worthless we want power
because power is a great disguise I even
feel odd calling myself a writer or a
screenwriter I do when I have to I put
it on my income tax form but I feel like
it's a lie even though it's technically
true if we live our lives striving to be
perfect and to know everything about our
chosen path then I honestly feel like
we've forgotten what it is that makes us
human
I mean a big part of the human
experience is knowing and understanding
that we are not going to understand
everything and that is what actually
makes life so exciting and it's what
makes us as humans so unique because
we're the ones with the intelligence and
the curiosity to actually try and find
those answers even though the answers
might not always be found curiosity is
what pushes humankind forever to find
out new solutions to our everyday
problems to create unique ideas that
nobody else has come up with before and
to push the boundaries of the knowledge
and industries that we as humans have
put in place because our collective we
still don't know it all and sure when we
try new things and embrace the unknown
there is a high chance that we are going
to fail
but there is no success without failure
so the sooner we become comfortable with
that fact and then the better will be
send stories out and and I pounded a
nail into the wall of my bedroom and
when I got the rejection slips back I
would put them on that nail and by the
time that I was 16 or 17 years old the
nail tore free from the plaster so I
just got a bigger nail and then when I
was 19 I sold a story to Starling
mystery stories it was called the glass
floor and they paid me like I think 35
bucks
that's my first sale so to summarize
this it's hard to be perfect but it's
even harder to accept the fact that
we're not but once you become
comfortable with that fact that's when
you allow yourself to become your
authentic self you don't have this
burden of needing to be something that
you can't bearing on your shoulders and
you can simply just carry on into the
unknown and enjoy whatever it is that
you want to do with your life so to stop
imposter syndrome we must understand
that we are not the best of what we do
we probably will never be the best of
what we do we won't know everything that
that ever is to know but if you're
trying and you're doing what you enjoy
and you're curious then that's all that
matters
you shouldn't have the pressure of
getting to the end and knowing it all to
hold you back
just enjoy the journey life is about
learning
not about knowing for have lovely day or
evening by
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you